please welcome somebody a couple i'm so
excited to talk to
from the people's court judge marilyn
milian
and john schlesinger
thank you for having us we're so excited
to be here great to be here
i've been so excited to speak with you
first of all i mean i'm totally single i
have two daughters so i have so much
love in my life my cup run is over in
fact any time i have a minute i'm like
can i just
be alone so believe me when i say i'm
single it's not a boohoo
it's an absolute empowered choice and
that said i always had like a fantasy
that if i
you know if i was to be with someone in
the past or in the future
my total like fantasy is to collaborate
with them
and i just think there's something so
darn groovy
about being able to have that and
wait a minute together together
it's so funny this was kind of a logical
progression though because when i was
a judge and she was taping in new york
sometimes
or in connecticut i had difficult issues
that would connect i'd call her from
chambers and say hey
i've got this this and this what do you
think and i bounce it off her and then
other days i'd get the phone call when
i'm in chambers
in my court outside of my courtroom and
it's her in connecticut or in new york
calling and saying
i've got this situation and before we
were judges we were both prosecutors i
was a state prosecutor and he was a
federal prosecutor so we would
we had the same kind when we were wooing
each other we would go to each other's
trials and give each other tips and
stuff so being in the same business
is is a a lot of fun but now we are
literally
literally inseparable yeah i mean we've
never imagined
i never imagined that it would look like
this where
our home life and our work life is all
blended together
no respite no hiding it's no hiding the
studio's in our living room this is
where we put our christmas tree now i
got to put my christmas tree on my head
in the kitchen basically
and i've seen you on other interviews
and although you
say you know that you're together all
the time
you always seem to be laughing about it
no it's
great it's magical like you have
like a really nice lightness no it's
it's a good thing i like my husband like
we always say that isn't it great that
we actually like each other because this
could really bomb if we didn't
we have different personalities and
that's actually worked
to strengthen the relationship because
she is a total
type triple a you know on top of every
detail
i'm a type b who's not quite the same
way
it's it's funny i tell people if we were
two animals
she's like a shark she never stops
moving it's just
on on on everywhere on to the next task
she's going to die if she stops moving
me i'm like a manatee i just kind of
bump around
on the grass here nibble on the grass
there
and you know they get along really well
sharks and manatees
it's funny because you mentioned the
type a type b i wanted to talk to you
guys because
i am a type b executor
with type a expectations oh wow
and i have a real issue with time
management i've worked on it
and i thought you know what i'm going to
lay down some accountability in my life
that i just simply cannot mess with
because i was always 5 10 15 20 minutes
later
but this has been my ongoing
you know sort of addiction if you will a
habit that i've wanted to break a cycle
i've wanted to break
and we're gonna go to commercial break
really quickly but when we come back
i was wondering with your type a and
type b because i relate to both of you
if you guys can give me some tips on
time management because
i know that well well i
i know so much about your process
because i've studied it with your alarm
clocks and your things and your blobbity
blocks but
i want to learn